from a wedding hall to hospital this is
the aftermath of a Saturday night
celebration a suicide bomber struck
during a wedding in Afghanistan's
capital killing scores of people buying
the place she wasn't done the explosion
happened near the stage where the
musicians were young people children
everyone who was nearby was killed
the attacker set off the explosives in
the men's reception area of the wedding
hall
witnesses say most of the guests were
members of the minority Shia Muslim
community there were a lot of victims
around 1200 guests were invited to the
wedding I was with the groom in the
other room when we heard the blast I
couldn't find anyone everyone was laying
on the floor all around the hall earlier
this month 14 people were killed in over
100 wounded when a car bomb was
detonated outside a police station in
West Kabul that blast and the wedding
attack occurred in the same area
it comes during ongoing talks between
the Taliban the United States and other
Afghan groups on the future of the
country a peace deal could include a
withdrawal of US troops of the Taliban
agrees to prevent attacks in areas it
controls but as negotiations continue so
have the attacks
Katya lo puso liuyan al Jazeera